nos piden que ordenemos los siguientes
números de menor a mayor y te invito a
que le pongas pausa al vídeo e intentes
hacerlo por tu cuenta
ordenar estos números de menor a mayor
bien ahora hagámoslo juntos
ninguno de estos números tiene valores a
la izquierda del punto decimal
aquí hay ser unidades ser unidades ser
unidades ser unidades ser unidades
vayamos entonces a la siguiente posición
numérica empezado en la mayor posición
decimal y de revisando los números
descendiendo en las posiciones así es
que ahora voy a ir a las décimas este
número tiene cero décimas este número
tiene cero décimas este número tiene
cero décimas este número tiene cero
décimas y este número si tiene tiene
siete décimas así es que este número lo
voy a dejar en esta posición pues
estamos ordenando de menor a mayor
vayamos ahora la posición de las
centésimas todos estos números tienen
cero décimas así es que vamos a la
posición de centésimas este número tiene
siete centésimas este número también
tiene siete centésimas
este número de aquí también tiene siete
centésimas y éste tiene cero centésimas
así es que este número es menor que
todos voy a moverlo al principio este es
el menor de todos los números este
número no tiene décimas no tiene
centésimas este de aquí tiene siete
décimas mientras que estos tres números
tienen la misma cantidad de centésimas
este tiene siete centésimas siete
centésimas y siete centésimas así es que
revisemos ahora la posición de milésimas
para estos tres números aquí hay nueve
milésimas
aquí tenemos cero milésimas y aquí
aunque no aparecen también tenemos cero
milésimas así es que este número es el
mayor de estos tres números que tienen
siete centésimas tiene nueve milésimas
mientras que estos otros dos números
tienen cero milésimas comparemos estos
dos números vámonos ahora el nivel de
las diez milésimas si bien aquí estos
dos números tienen cero milésimas
aquí hay cero milésimas y aquí ese dos
milésimas éste tiene nueve diez
milésimas mientras que éste no tiene
diez milésimas así es que este número es
menor y ya está ya hemos concluido
ordenado los números de menor a mayor y
la clave aquí es checar las posiciones
numéricas que son más significativas o
podríamos decir que tienen el mayor
valor aquí empezamos con las unidades y
a partir de ahí vamos descendiendo en
esas posiciones comparando los números
entre sí hasta que logramos un
ordenamiento adecuado